what's the difference between double
equal signs and triple equal signs well
double equal signs tests for abstract
equality while triple equal signs the
test for restrict equality the
difference is that abstract equality
will attempt to resolve the data types
via type coercion before making it
comparison while strict equality will
return false if the types are different
let me give you an example if we test
for abstract equality with two equal
signs here we get true in the console
however I'm going to just copy this
piece then we're gonna put a third a
third equal sign and run this again and
you can see true that's the first one
false that's the second one here so in
this using two equal signs returns true
because the string 3 is converted to the
number 3 before the comparison is made
but with 3 equal signs it sees that the
types are different ones the number
one's a string and then it returns false
here's another example you can see that
it's showing that true is equal equal to
1 for abstract equality equals 1 however
if we check it for strict equality so
that's the equal equal true equals
equals 1 here is true equal equal equals
1 with the two equal signs this one is
convert to true because in JavaScript
true is 1 and false is 0
however the with the 3 equal signs this
one is not converted so it's false I
want to show you another interesting
thing with this
we clear the console and run this you
can see the last one here this is true
however if we copy this line and we do
three equal signs and run this in dual
show false at the end this is
interesting because it illustrates that
string literals are different than
string objects so this first part of the
string literal this is a string object
with the two equal signs it converts the
object to the literal to compare them
but then when the three equal signs the
string literal is there it is different
than the string object so which one is
better to use the two equal signs or the
three equal signs well in general it is
always best to use the three equal signs
that test for strict equality this will
increase the clarity of your code and
prevent any false positives caused by
abstract equality comparison if you do
need to compare values of different
types first do the conversions yourself
and then compare this makes your code
more explicit which is always better
well thanks for watching my name is Bo
Carnes and remember use your code for
good